the the nice guys i talk about it
operates like i said from what i call
covert contracts is they're if then
propositions and there's three primary
covert contracts of nice guy syndrome
this be true for guys or girls one is
that if i'm a good person then i'll be
liked and loved uh for most men that
also manifest and the women that i
desire to have sex with will want to
have sex with me if i'm a good guy
they'll want to be with me
second covert contract is that if i meet
everybody else's needs without them
having to ask then they will meet my
needs without me having to ask now as
you can imagine that that's not a very
functional way of relating to other
people
third covert contract of nice guy
syndrome is if i do everything right
then i'll have a smooth problem free
life
and this is kind of a
that's what gets me i think yeah i do
too i follow hey hey i did everything
right how come you're upset at me you
know you should you should do nothing
but make my life easy and praise me and
appreciate me i'm the same way so
but it's a very immature peter panish oh
if i get everything right everything in
my life will work well but a couple
problems with that is nobody ever gets
everything right we're human we're we're
we're
we're flawed you know we're imperfect
and the other part of that is we don't
live in a smooth problem-free perfect
world we live in a chaotic world
and in accepting that the world is
chaotic is one step towards maturity
because then we quit trying to manage
the chaos um and so going back to your
question then
if you are not operating from covert
contracts if you're not giving to get
and then the way i often put it if
you're not giving from an empty bucket
where most codependents nice guys nice
girls are because we're not good at
making our own needs a priority our
bucket's empty we give to others hoping
that they will then give back which
means that our bucket doesn't usually
get filled and we often have a lot of
guilt around taking good care of
ourselves or meeting our own needs or
making ourselves a priority when when i
tell nice guys you need to make yourself
your number one priority in life they
get a deer in the headlight looks oh no
that'll make me a bad person that'll
make me like my father or all those
jerks i've heard women complain about
but no the a true sign of maturity in
fact i think the number one
characteristics of a mature adult is a
person who takes full responsibility for
both their actions and their needs and
their wants now we can't get all of our
needs and wants met by ourselves now we
can get a good start at it we can get up
and drink water and do some exercise and
do some meditation we can do a lot of
things to nurture ourselves but we need
a lot of people around us we need a
posse i call these cooperative
reciprocal relationships we need a lot
of both friends professionals practices
different things that fill our bucket
from there we can give from the overflow
and we can we can be generous and we can
bless other people's lives and we can
give to them what they need to receive
not what we need to give
out of our covert contract coming from a
place of emptiness so to come back to
your question
if you are taking good care of you which
is essential if you're going to give to
anybody else if you're filling your own
bucket in a consistent way
that makes you feel loved and lovable
and then you can give from the overflow
with no strings attached no covert
contracts and give to people what they
most need to receive not what you most
need to give to get your covert
contracts met
so yeah you know i i think i heard you
mentioned you have a young child
yes okay scarlett she's she's almost
four okay so here's an example of what i
call two levels of differentiation
first level of differentiation is where
you ask yourself what feels right to me
what do i want what do i need what's
important to me and then you take action
to to do that and again you do it even
when you experience the resistance of
neurotic guilt or change back from the
people around you
now there's a second level of
differentiation that can only occur
after you've
achieved first level differentiation and
then you can also ask what is in the
best interest of the people i love what
is in the best interest of the planet
that i live on right and and now from
that place you might actually make some
sacrifices you might actually put
yourself second in order to put somebody
you love first that needs to be
especially a child or a an ill parent my
mother is 86 and had a stroke coming up
on three years ago she lives alone she
can still drive but she's fairly
disabled physically and you know i live
in mexico she lives in seattle i get up
there at least every other month and
people oh you go up to see your mom a
lot they go yeah i go up because she
lives alone you know she she doesn't
have a lot of social connection she
can't get out a lot um i go make sure
you know her during covid you know her
pantry is well stocked and that she
doesn't have to do a costco run by
herself and so
i can take care of my mother in
differentiated ways now as a child i
tried to take care of her in codependent
ways because i thought my
my
ability to thrive and survive depended
on me sacrificing me to take care of her
i'm now a differentiated adult and i can
make sacrifices or i can go out of my
way to do things for her